- [Woman] How do you
approach a challenge?
- I like challenges.
One of the reasons I love being
a Jets fan is that they lose.
A lot and I'm much
more into the journey.
I look at challenges as
the narratives of my career.
Whether this is
egotistical or a nice thing,
I'm not quite sure but
I do think of things
in the body of my work.
The book will be very
boring if everything's easy.
You know, you need the arc and
so when I see challenges,
I don't think that you
get to have the luxuries
that come along with being
a leader or CEO or a founder.
If I want this,
if I want the attention,
if I want the fruits of the
things that come along with it,
I have to be respectful that
challenges come along with it
so when they come to me
I really kind of,
I'll paint you a picture.
I genuinely love
the scene in the movie,
the cliche scene where the
person gets
punched in the mouth,
turns, blood comes out,
spits out his tooth
and then looks back at the
other person like, "Now, what?"
That's how I
think about challenges.
I weirdly want,
I almost, can I get
weird with you for a second?
- [Woman] Yeah, you
can get weird with me.
- I even think sometimes
I fabricate challenges
because I enjoy that
more than the easy sailing.
And so, I think any
true purebred entrepreneur
has the stomach
for challenges and
so for me it's just
part of the equation.
(light music)